the Joe Rogan experience who do look you
have a very hard look she said you look
like a meathead she goes you don't want
to like give people face I knew you had
it you looked your face one time you
were interviewing Randy Couture and you
had a wider head than Randy so that's
not true that shows what's weird is that
you can always bring a conversation
around to a man's Anatomy that's what's
weird
that's true that is what's weird and now
speaking of anatomy yeah you're getting
older hey but no it's good so when I saw
you when I see old videos of you look
healthy and now you don't not look
healthy yeah but you look less no right
you look less listen man you look like
you're wearing a Bryan Callen mask
so don't ever [ __ ] listen no no no
okay what now this is my house number
one you're welcome for Joe Rogan right
no I know we're and now we're closer
than you know he promised he said he
says hey I go what he goes it's Chris
D'Elia kid you know and I said I said
what he goes and I go all right okay oh
so you get oh yeah you got blessing the
door open now if I want to shut the door
I got glance at him wrong I glanced at
him and you're banned okay
do the presses show with a wife-beater
on just just lost a wife-beater please
look dude I'm not gonna sit here what
you're what's up dude I just don't
understand how many layers you have when
it's 80 degrees outside unbelievable you
look like a [ __ ] tell me tell me
right now you're watching a play about
the 40's and then this and then halfway
through he comes in you're like that's
the trouble that's a guy worth
construction where's my beer there you
go he's one of those guys that you know
those you're not like ma yeah cuz you're
gonna die soon no you know those girders
where the guys are eating lunch and
they're like Fay t-80 [ __ ] stories
yeah yeah yeah clapper said you're on
say right you're on the picture of all
the guys sitting on the beam there's no
wasted space on my body you body you
know what I mean I'm not if you're a
building first of all I be condemned
right
if I was a building I think I'd be more
force than you that's what I would be
forcing you look at the picture don't
use each and every one of those guys
right there the guy right there that's
him but what's up with savages just
sitting there
unbelievable lunch Rock with their hands
look at lunchbox doesn't mean you don't
even know him to kill a baby you wasting
away hey yay you only got from Christmas
know where the day well I sent a video
and he goes I just got this I got a text
you look gone huh gone huh yeah my
necklace Bachmann says that you're in
your 50s I know but my face is more
symmetrical too but why does it make
your neck look thicker just from
training here is training what dolphin
sniffing I got you that's a [ __ ] burn
dude it's not that's the hardest for you
and this stupid bar I [ __ ] burn you
you do I for myself good [ __ ] it you
wearing Gucci Gucci loafers huh nope I'm
not gonna show ya you know why because I
just got tested I'm negative and you
probably about coveting I have to get my
finger pricked I'm very squeamish about
that nobody real your hearts beating can
you do my spor arm your nose is your
heart make that thing small hey weird
your noses get bigger something we can
take tea I forgot it's cold but I gave
it to me let me ask you a question man
you are your hearts beating extra fast
because you got to get your finger
pricked or because you're in a room with
us be honest you in a room with us no no
two young guns
[Laughter]
[Applause]